the ice rink at the cosmopolitan
provides plenty of festive fun
with the fire pits the seasonal drinks
and of course impressive ice skating
from jc fernandez a former hockey player
he's live there now tearing up the rink
jc that's right brian actually played
for our las vegas thunder back in the
90s bet you didn't know that
uh this is fedora with the cosmopolitan
let's talk about safety because i'm
watching people
ice skating this guy back here first
time ice skater he's doing a really good
job
talk about some of the safety features
you have for first-time skaters here at
the cosmopolitan well first off jc if
you don't know how to skate and you want
it we have helmets available they're
free of charge
and we have all sizes for adults and
kids and for those that
want extra help we have walkers and
skate aids like the seal
where you can push off and you can also
have children sitting on them and the
parents can push
their child on the ice it's like
training wheels
and you're telling me too when it comes
to skating a lot of people they stand up
straight that's not what you want to be
doing when you're ice skating you want
to like
put your legs parallel lean a little
forward to get your center of gravity
going and then push off and glide all
right let's head out here so
the ice skating the ice rink is is like
kind of the main event here but there's
so much more oh jimmy's fall
there's so much more happening let's
talk about the movies and date night
that you have
so every monday and tuesdays we have
holiday classics it's starting this
tuesday
with a nightmare before uh christmas the
night before christmas and we've got elf
we've got the holiday a lot of a lot of
favorites
so we're talking ice skating watching
right on the moon right here
rent the fire pit have a small have
s'mores and uh dinner
it's a great great uh holiday fun with
your family oh yeah i'm sure sabina
family a lot of families want to come
down here
and let their kids go ice skating maybe
mom and dad want to sit and watch
talk to me about the cocktails oh we
have we have a full selection of holiday
cocktails camp our delight's a big
favorite the griswold's another big
favorite
uh the food selection is amazing the
beef empanadas are great
you can really have a you can enjoy
yourself out here in the atmosphere you
don't have to skate if you don't want to
it's free of charge to come out here the
view is just spectacular as the sun
sun is set the lights you guys have set
up the view is spectacular as far as
getting in here
how much does it cost to come down here
and soak in the atmosphere it's free
it's free to it's free to come and enjoy
the atmosphere and and have food and
and and hang out at the bar and get some
stuff to eat i got to wrap it up let's
do some fedora go to that wall over
there i want to try something
real quick i know i got i know i want i
want to try something so he's right
there
all right you stop it you ready
three two play goaltender
i would i would never i would never do
such a thing he doesn't have pads on so
i can't i can't hit the puck okay
you know what's cool though kirsten jc
of course played professional hockey for
the thunder yet he's taken it down a
notch
showing his humility by going so easy on
some of the other
participants there i mean we know he
could be zipping around that ring
and he's really just taking it down jc
you're a humble guy
and remember right he pretends that he
doesn't know how to stop
yeah yeah he does this whole i don't
know how to stop i don't know how to
stop
he couldn't stop on a dime guys i did it
jc show just uh i can't stop jc show a
glimpse of your thunder days
right we're getting the hard drive right
here we're not hearing anything we gotta
go
oh didn't hear her hi bye brian all
right ted
great we need to clarify that it wasn't
the las vegas thunder
that he played for it was the las vegas
thunder from down under
just to clarify all right